Salut. Ces lunettes censurent mon visage. Vous ne savez donc pas qui je suis.
Je vais désormais les retirer et vous découvrirez qui se cache derrière.
Brad Pitt.
Les amis, je me suis souvenu d'un site qui m'a rendu profondément – je me suis retenu de l'utiliser – mais ça m'a rendu nostalgique
juste de revoir le nom.
C'est Web Archive! « web.archive.org », est-ce que vous connaissez?
Oui, non, peut-être
Osef, j'préfères les tutos beauté
TU TE CALMES!
En gros, tu peux sauvegarder une page.
Par exemple, j'peux sauvegarder actuellement, euh.. bah le lien de ma chaîne YouTube.
Comme ceci.
Hop! J'la sauvegarde, et dans... 5 ans, 6 ans, quand j'retournerai sur Web Archive
eh ben je pourrai voir à quoi ressemblait ma chaîne YouTube, au moment où j'ai fait cette archive.
En 2021-2022, si on est encore sur YouTube, mec, on pourra regarder cette archive!
C'est magnifique!
Eh bien on va commencer par ma chaîne YouTube: regarder la plus vieille archive.
Et j'remercie la personne qui a.. qui l'a fait, parce que c'est pas automatique, j'crois hein.
Elle date de: avril 2016!
Regardez, ça vous rappelle des souvenirs. On était à 5 856 000  abonnés
et on avait ce.. ce.. ce fond-là.
Et je venais de sortir le Clavier Challenge!
Attends, mais c'est il y a pas si longtemps, ça.
19 avril 2016.
C'est il y a plus d'un an!
Le temps passe vite!
Qu'est-ce qui nous arrive?
Septembre 2011, non...
Qui aurait sauvegardé un truc de septembre 2011.. mais ça va pas! Personne fait ça.
Ooooooh!!!
Le 10 octobre 2011: voilà à quoi ça ressemblait. Alors, les plus jeunes d'entre vous serons totalement choqués par la gueule qu'avait YouTube
mais ça avait vraiment cette gueule!
Ça c'était la photo de ma chaîne!
Mec, ça paraît tellement loin, c'est.. excellent!
J'avais 8 857 abonnés. Oui, c'est comme ça que c'était affiché, j'me souviens!
Putain! Ça me fait un truc, de revoir ça!
« Le youtuber le plus déjanté de youtube vous offre ses Crazy Commentaries! :D »
Héhé...
Bon!
« J'aime aussi que l'on m'envoie des idées, des beaux kills, des fails, voir même des critiques négatives afin de m'améliorer. »
Car je n'arrive pas à faire des vidéos sans l'aide des gens.
Avril 2012! Ça c'était.. Ah ça putain c'est, woah, c'était un vrai... une vraie évolution, j'trouve, de YouTube. Vous avez vu?
Donc là, j'avais changé mon fond et j'avais pu mettre une petite bannière, et tu pouvais mettre des liens cliquables!
Eh oui mon ami!
Et j'avais 9 500 000 (9 553 061) vues au total, et 85 000 (85 132) abonnés!
Ça j'en garde un très très bon souvenir, de cette époque. C'tait vraiment THE époque!
J'commençais à faire des jeux d'horreur, j'me souviens.
« SCP-087 » c'était le premier jeu d'horreur que j'faisais.
Il y avait un peu de podcasts, enfin bref.. Le vieux vieux YouTube, quoi!
En 2013, qu'est-ce qui avait?
D'accord, ouais donc là on.. Oh pff wouah! J'avais mis un.. un.. il y avait un bug, avec mon image YouTube! C'est totalement honteux!
Ok, et ensuite, en juin 2014, bah c'tait les dizaines qu'on a connues pendant très très très longtemps!
BREF!
Mec, j'me demande à quoi, parce que j'étais pas là, au tout début de Twitter. À quoi ressemblait Twitter, mec?
Oh! En 2001, tiens! En 2001, c'est très bien, ça!
Oh mais c'est pas siii... ça fait un peu vieillot, mais c'est pas siii... terrible, j'trouve.
C'est gentil! Aujourd'hui, tu pourrais encore tomber sur des sites comme ça et ça t'ferais pas paniquer.
Alors 2006, vas-y! On va peut-être pas remonter trop. On va aller en 2006. Comment c'était en 2006?
Ooooh! Oh oh oh oh!
Mec, mais c'est vide! Mais c'est.. mais non, mais il manque un fond, c'est pas possible.
« Une communauté d'amis et d'étrangers qui répondent à une seule et simple question: qu'es-tu en train de faire? »
À la base c'était juste ça. C'était juste un statut disant c'que t'es en train de faire!
Je savais pas! Moi j'ai rejoint Twitter euh, très tard, en 2012-13, je sais plus.
J'ai rejoint super tard, donc je.. c'est marrant d'voir, à la base, pourquoi le réseau social était.. est.. était né, en fait!
J'me demande à quoi ressemblait la chaîne YouTube de Natoo, par exmple, à l'époque.
En 2011! Mais là, mec, à 9h21 du matin, le 30 novembre 2011, qui a archivé la chaîne YouTube de Natoo, c'est incroyable!
Woaaah!
« Les chroniques d'une fille ludique » Ah, c'tait déjà ça!
« Tuto chirurgie esthétique cheap »
*rire*
Elle était déjà dans la bêtise, hein!
« Le Pubis », « Ma copine qui vient de se faire larguer ». Ah! C'est génial!
Et Norman Fait Des Vidéos, à la même période, j'crois que c'était déjà euh... surpuissant.
Ooooh! Meeec.. MEC! C'est génial! Regarde ça!
Oh! Regarde le vieux Like! Le vieux Like et le vieux Dislike, à l'ancienne.
Et tu pouvais mettre des commentaires sur la chaîne, c'est vrai! Il y en avait 8.
Il s'était abonné à Jean-Pierre Herlant. Ah mais oui, c'était quoi ça déjà Jean-Pierre Herlant?
C'tait pas l'mec qui disait « tu triquites » au lieu de dire « vous critiquez »? J'crois que c'était ça..
Aaah ouiii! Ça fait plaisir de le revoir!
C'est génial! « Arrêtez de me triquiter », je m'en souviens très bien!
On a pas fait MonsieurDream! On a pas fait MonsieurDream!
Alors, Cyprien.. Ooooh! Cyprien, il a une archive de 2009, mec!
C'est lui-même qui l'a fait, c'est obligé.
Ooooh! On est sur du vieux truc.
Mais attends, c'est vraiment la chaîne de Cyprien?
Mais pourquoi il a mis cette photo? *rire*
120 (121) ABONNÉS! DAMMIT!
« il sont stupide tes video ». Ah il y avait déjà des haineux à l'époque, c'est... Clairement!
« Très sympa ton vidéo Blog »
*rire*
Il avait en Favoris: We Will Rock You, mais surtout, Plouf, des Wriggles, mec!
Qui connaît ça?
C'est mon frère, Florent Hauchard le hipster, qui m'avait fait découvrir ça, mec!
C'était dans la lignée de Trio, et des gens qui fument de la plante.
... "avec son père!" Ouiii, je m'en souviens!
Juin 2011, c'est là en fait où ça commençait vraiment à exploser, YouTube, j'ai l'impression.
Cyprien, il faisait des 200 000-300 000 vues..
J'avais l'impression qu'en 2011, ils avaient déjà beaucoup plus, euh... Cyprien, Norman, Natoo, etc.
En fait, pas du tout. C'est vraiment à partir de là, que ça a complètement décollé.. C'est marrant.
Oh, putain oui! Ils te mettaient des badges, à l'époque!
« Celui qui a le plus d'abonnés de tous les temps – Comédien en France »
Ils te mettaient des espèces de.. de médailles, comme ça. J'me souviens que j'en avais, aussi.
Il avait 4 500 000 (4 584 526) vues au total, là.
19 000 (19 180) abonnés.
Mais en fait, à l'époque, il y a vraiment eu un moment, où YouTube, ils ont mis en place ce truc d'abonnements. À la base, c'était pas comme ça.
À la base, l'abonnement il y avait le gros bouton Subscribe, mais déjà, il faisait peur.
Déjà, quand tu cliquais, tu savais pas ce qu'il pourrait arriver à ta famille
et ensuite tu t'en foutais un peu. Tu te laissais guider par la plateforme, les suggestions, ce qu'ils te mettaient en avant comme vidéos...
C'est pour ça que c'était essentiellement des vidéos de chats, qui marchaient.
Il y avait pas cette fidélisation qu'il y a, actuellement.
D'ailleurs, j'pense c'est peu de temps après.. J'pense ça devait être en 2012. Juste avant la fin du monde.
Parce qu'ils ont mis le design d'après. Voilà, celui-là.
À partir de là, ils ont commencé à influencer les gens à s'abonner.
Donc là on est 1 an après.
Février 2012. Et là, t'es presque à 90 000 000 (89 685 130) de vues et à 330 000 (332 084) abonnés.
Donc on voit qu'il y a vraiment un gap entre les 20 000, les 330 000, le design.. Les vues, aussi!
YouTube a vraiment explosé en 2011-2012. Et moi j'étais là en mars 2011, mais j'ai explosé euh... mon compte en banque.
Pour acheter de quoi faire des vidéos mais clairement pas euh... le buzz.
*rire*
Si j'mets juste YouTube tout court, parce que là je suis sur des chaînes YouTube. Mais j'pense YouTube tout court, on aura des archives bien bien vieilles.
C'est là. Avril 2005.
Mec!
C'est totalement affreux. C'est totalement ignoble. C'est génial!
Eh, il y avait déjà le délire de pseudos pour s'identifier.
Et, ah oui c'est vrai! Il fallait dire, si t'étais un homme ou une femme, qui cherchait un homme ou une femme entre tel et tel â..
C'tait totalement un site de rencontre, en fait.
« Favoris », « messages », « vidéos », « mon profil ».
Attends! Mais oui!
« À sa création, YouTube devait être un site de rencontre »
« L'idée était simple et ingénieuse, les personnes qui recherchaient l'amour pouvaient poster une vidéo pour se présenter et dire ce qu'ils recherchaient. »
Putain, c'est génial!
L'histoire de YouTube, mec!
Donc là, on est en avril 2005. Si j'vais en avril 2006, logiquement, l'interface aurait dû, déjà, être normalement changée à ce moment-là.
Oh là là! Ok, il y a la moitié des trucs qui se chargent pas.
Putain, celui.. ce design-là je l'ai pas connu, tu vois.
Ooooh, 2008! Voilà, ok, ben c'est... c'est comme ça que je l'ai connu, YouTube. C'est avec CE design-là!
En 2008, j'avais 12 ans et j'devais probablement taper "Dofus", dans cette barre juste ici.
*rire*
Là, il y avait déjà, une vraie mise en avant de certaines vidéos..
Ah oui! Et tu te notais en mettant des étoiles, c'est vrai putain!
C'est moi! C'est ce You.. C'est CE YouTube-là que j'ai connu. En premier, c'était celui-là!
Voilà, tout ça pour dire que j'ai envie de voir, du coup, à quoi ressemblait le site Dofus!
22 septembre 2007
Ouiiiii! Héhé, je reconnais!
Meeec! C'était fou!
J'avais 11 ans, j'étais le plus gros kikou de la planète Terre!
J'avais droppé une maîtrise d'armes dans Dofus, la maîtrise des dagues, j'crois, j'en pouvais plus!
J'tais un vrai kikou.
Qu'est-ce qu'on peut se mater d'autres?
Ah, ben Google!
Pff.. le con!
Ooooh, 2001!
Là on est sur de l'ancienneté COLOSSALE.
2001, mec, j'avais 5 ans, faut pas abuser.
Bah mec, ça a pas tant vieilli.. Mais à l'époque je.. ils adoraient mettre plein de boutons, comme ça.
"Alors coche des choses inutiles. Clique sur ça, on sait pas à quoi ça sert. Et là, tu as aussi des boutons. Et ici..."
Ils adoraient faire ça. Et maintenant, regardez, c'est vraiment l'inverse.
T'as juste "Google", une barre et 2 boutons.
Ben mec, ça a pas tant vieilli, Google. Non You.. YouTube j'trouve qu'ils ont eu vraiment plusieurs faces de... On voyait qu'ils se cherchaient, en fait.
Ils cherchaient quelle direction ils voulaient que la plateforme prenne
alors que Google.. Google en fait c'est... c'est.. à l'époque c'est... l'idée était déjà géniale en fait. Ils ont pas modifié tren.. tant de trucs.
Par contre! Maintenant, il y a beaucoup d'outils: il y a Google Docs, Google Sheets, euh...
Google euh.... GOOGLE!
J'ai Gmail, Google Drive, Google Maps...
Ils ont sorti plein d'outils, mais l'truc de base est resté quasiment le même, c'est rigolo.
Est-ce que c'est nul, c'que j'dis? Oui.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y avait?
Ah mec! Absoluflash! Absoluflash ça ressemblait à quoi?
Ooooh! Oh oui!
Mec, c'était fou!
Est-ce que vous vous souvenez d'ce pingouin? Est-ce que vous vous en souvenez, de.. de ce pingouin?
C'est ça que j'imaginais quand je vous parlais d'Absoluflash!
C'est incroyable! C'est le vrai putain d'Absoluflash!
C'est terrible comme les sites web de jeux flashs sont morts.
Maintenant l'équivalent des jeux flashs c'est les jeux mobiles, en fait. C'est terrible! C'est fou!
Je suis étonné pour rien, aujourd'hui! Aujourd'hui, je suis étonné pour rien!
C'est incroyable, j'vais dans la rue, là! J'vais voir un mec acheter une baguette, j'vais être.. j'vais faire "Wow c'est incroyable!"
Eh bien les amis, je crois qu'on a visité assez de sites web datant des années 2000.
*rire*
On a eu assez de nostalgie pour aujourd'hui. N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu
et putain, mec, c'est... J'trouve ça génial de pouvoir voir, euh.. comment
un outil que tu utilises absolument tous les jours, à l'heure actuelle..
Comment est-ce que c'était à l'époque, tu vois.
Au début, en plus, parce que c'est... c'est.. ça fait pas si longtemps qu'il y a Internet, hein.
Nos parents ils ont grandi, ils avaient pas Internet.
J'ai hâte, d'être dans 10 ans
et de regarder euh.. cette vidéo! Et de rire, en m'disant: "Haha! Comme c'était naze!"
Ah, voir Absoluflash, ça m'a fait plaisir! Et le p'tit Dofus aussi, putain, mec!
Cet écran-là, qui m'a fait perdre 4 ans de vie sociale. J'men souviens, ouais.
*rire*
Allez, c'est la fin d'la nostalgie. Merci d'avoir regardé! J'vous dis à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo, pour se taper
des baaarres!
J'arrête ce mimique... dégueulasse!
*musique d'outro*